[Applause]
[Music]
so uh
the award goes too
best male lead is simon rex for red
rocky man
this is simon rex's first nomination and
his first win
rex got his start in pornographic films
and later he went on to work as an mtv
ej
[Music]
tonight he wins his first
film independence spirit award
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
what the fuck
thank you film independent for
recognizing my fake penis
um where do i begin uh
sean baker
sean baker you took a shot on me when i
could not get a call back for a geico
commercial
i couldn't get arrested and this man
believed in me and took a shot and i'm
so glad i delivered for you sean truly
you're a genius
writer director editor casting he did it
all and he decided to give me a shot and
i didn't want to let him down and here i
am
i honestly my career was in the toilet i
gave up i moved out to joshua tree and
said maybe it's all over
and all of a sudden i get a phone call
out of the blue from sean and he just
gave me a shot and he called me and said
look do you trust me and i seen his film
so i did trust him
and
he said you're not going to make any
money i'm not going to make any money
we're going to go make a movie real
quick
and we made something special um
on a very low budget with a 10 person
crew i want to thank everybody from the
crew of the film everyone in the cast
susanna sawn my co-star thank you so
much i want to thank brie elrod my other
co-star in the love triangle every local
actor from texas who was a first time
actor
they blew me away this was like one of
those magical things that happens once
in a lifetime
and i don't even i'm still in shock we
shot this during covid
even finishing this movie was ambitious
and
uh i i'm reeling from the whole
experience um so also
you know thank you to film independent
everybody thank you a24 thank you film
nation thank you lepak thank you focus
universal
everybody who was a part of this i could
not have done this alone i was just a
part of a machine that was a lot bigger
than me and i
uh yeah i'm just so grateful for sean's
trust in me and and uh
i don't even know what the hell's going
on but i'll take it i'll take it and all
i want to do i don't care about fame or
money i got caught in that trap a long
time ago i've been in this business 25
years
and it's not about anything except doing
good work i just want to continue to
surprise people and do good work and
that's really what this is all about
this movie was made for a million
dollars with a 10 person crew with no
permits we were hiding from police we
were hiding from neighbors i was running
down the street butt naked
like
if this doesn't embody
like the spirit award of an independent
film i don't know what does this is
basically a glorified student film
and
i'll take this all day long so thank you
thank you thank you i'm truly humbled
and honored thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]